[Music]
hello everybody thank you for coming my
name is Andy Waddell and I'm a technical
program manager here in Google cloud and
it is my great pleasure to introduce you
today to a new service offering from our
partner IBM the name of the offer is IBM
power systems for Google cloud and it's
a new infrastructure as a service
offering that you'll be hearing about
today before I introduce you to my IBM
colleagues you're gonna run most of the
presentation including showing you a
real live demo I want to emphasize a
little bit about what it means to be an
integrated service with Google cloud so
the name of the offer again is IBM power
systems for Google cloud so what is the
for Google cloud part mean and what we
what we hear time and time again and
what we've learned throughout doing
trials of this is that our end customers
want to consume a third party service
but very much in the same way they are
used to consuming a first party Google
service so like Google compute engine
Google Cloud Storage and that could mean
a lot of things but for the initial
integration effort on this offer we
focused on four areas and I just want to
highlight those areas and then we're
gonna have lots of demo time the first
is billing and we've integrated the
billing such that you you would purchase
this offer from IBM through the Google
cloud marketplace the billing is done
through Google and it will show up on
your cloud bill as a line item along
with all the Google services you consume
it's all gonna be offered on a monthly
subscription basis based on well we'll
get into that based on the the amount of
infrastructure you wish to subscribe to
the second is the the user experience
and this means that when you're when
you're interacting with with IBM
infrastructure it should be just like
you're interacting with Google
infrastructure that's the web UI the
command-line tools the API
I'm really excited to that what you're
going to see is a brand new set of
capabilities that the IBM Power Systems
software team has developed to to make
this you know a good match for google
cloud i'll leave most of that for the
demo the third area is networking and we
spent a lot of time carefully
architecting the network architecture
between the IBM resources and the google
cloud resources to ensure a very little
latency connection one that is highly
available and fault tolerant and can
also scale up as demand grows and most
importantly is very secure so we'll
touch on this a little bit later but
when you connect to the infrastructure
from IBM you're never going over the
internet it's all done in private IP
space that you get to define as a
customer and the last one is not as
technical but it's equally important
which is customer support so we're
expecting you'll put some very critical
workloads on this infrastructure and we
want to support that so Google has
stepped up and is going to do Tier one
support for this offer so what that
means is if you have an incident you'll
contact the Google support at whatever
tier you already with Google will take
command of that incident and if we need
to escalate to IBM four will do that
transparently and resolve the issue for
you and so with that introduction I'd
like to introduce a colleague at IBM
Carl Burnett Carl's a distinguished
engineer in the IBM power system
software group and he's going to lead
you through a small deck and then we'll
have a demo time and question and answer
at the end thank you thank you Andy so
good afternoon everyone before I get
started I want to do one more intro Kyle
Johnson is colleague of mine from IBM
one of our senior developers and he's
going to take you through a live
demonstration of what we've been working
on later in the presentation
so hybrid multi-cloud is a very
important part of IBM's overall strategy
and it's really about bringing our IBM
solutions to the customer wherever they
are on their cloud journey whether it's
on Prem or off Prem in different off
Prem you know IT models and there are
industry studies that reveal that most
enterprises will continue to run some
portion of their their IT and their
solutions in their own data centers but
at the same time most of those customers
are on a journey to run some of their IT
infrastructure off Prem and hosted
environments public cloud environments
business partner managed solution
environments and of those clients that
are exploring these different options on
average they're looking at at least four
off Prem options for their solutions so
bringing power systems onto Google cloud
gives our customers another great option
as they go down that journey with on and
off Prem IT infrastructure the solution
we're building is an infrastructure as a
service solution and it's based on our
IBM power systems running our power VM
virtualization stack
it's the subscription model is actually
a capacity for subscription model with a
monthly price and it's built on a
concept we call a cloud instance so
think of a cloud instance as a bundle of
compute memory storage and network you
then take that cloud instance and we
give you a user experience so that you
can create and manage one or more
virtual machines within that slice of
infrastructure okay so that's a cloud
instance you might also hear me refer to
it as a t-shirt as we go through the
presentation because we think of them
like t-shirt sizes small medium large
extra-large and so forth now in the
solution
IBM runs the infrastructure so we're
managing the
hardware the system software stack if
you're familiar with power systems
you know those different hardware
elements like our HMC and so forth so
we're taking care of that maintaining it
patching it you know but once the
virtual machine is deployed with a
running operating system it's the
subscribers responsibility to manage and
maintain the operating system in the
stack up I want to just do one quick
show of hands how many of you are
familiar with power systems terminology
like el pars and HMCS
okay great so I'm talking to a crowd who
knows knows our vocabulary very good now
the last part of this solution involves
a low latency interconnect or network
between our power infrastructure
footprint and GCP and this gives you a
private low latency network between GCP
resources and power resources so for
example if you need to run a database on
power on the back end and you want to
run your app tier on GCP compute right
there they're close to each other
they're connected on a low latency
network and you can run that hybrid
workload if you need to store your data
in DCP cloud storage we've got a private
you know you're inside the Google
Network you can use GCP Cloud Storage
from your you know your AIX instance for
example ok
um while it is an IBM solution you'll
subscribe to it through GCP marketplace
so just like you subscribe to other
resources and offerings through the
marketplace there'll be a tile for power
systems you see an example draft of that
tile here and this is where you'll go
and and see the different cloud plans
that you can purchase the cloud instance
plans and here's just a simple example
of what we might call a starter cloud
with 16 cores 160 gig of ram and 12
terabytes of storage and then you can
take that and partition that up into
virtual machines I mentioned earlier we
think of these in t-shirt sizes so an
experience you'll be able to have
through the marketplace is that as your
needs grow or is as your your journey
here evolves you can change plans so
let's say you start with a small t-shirt
and then you get to a point where you
realize you need more capacity you can
upgrade to a medium t-shirt or a large
t-shirt and maybe you only need to do
that for a temporary basis and then you
can go back to let's say from a medium
t-shirt to a small t-shirt you can
downgrade as well so the GCP marketplace
allows you to do that okay so what's
under the hood so we're starting with
power 9 technology that's our latest
generation of power and we've built an
infrastructure concept we call a pod
think of a pod as multiple racks of
equipment that we've put together for
you while we're starting with our two
socket 922 systems our architecture is
such that we can incorporate any of our
power VM based servers into this
environment so we could put a hundred
and ninety two core 64 terabytes server
in this infrastructure and it integrates
into GCP the same way that that two
socket server does okay
it's fiber channel connected storage
we're leveraging 25 gig networking down
at the server's 100 gigabit across the
racks and then that feeds up into a an
interconnect ear to GCP
from a system software perspective it's
the same power VM stack that you're
probably deploying in your own data
center or if you're a partner it's what
you've been building and servicing for
your clients my key point here is this
is the same type of infrastructure that
you deploy and use in your own data
centers it's a you know it's fully
compatible that's by design it's the
same infrastructure that we've done all
our eyes and certifications with and so
forth so to manage your cloud instance
we've built a new management experience
completely from the ground up and it
starts with an open API compliant REST
API that we've built we've actually
built it on GCP it actually runs on
google kubernetes engine it's a micro
services based architecture and that API
is what sits on top of our
infrastructure footprint and provides
you know all the operations for virtual
machine lifecycle management and general
service management so everything from
creating a new VM or L part to stopping
starting modifying it you know
ultimately deleting it it comes to
end-of-life and we've also put in
functionality around managing your boot
images or your your VM images that you
can bring your VM images from your own
data center up into the cloud we'll have
some stock images for you and then also
managing your storage what we call your
data volumes and Kyle's going to show
you a little bit more detail on that
later in the presentation on top of that
API we've built a couple of user
interface experiences for you one is a
web console experience and you might
notice it has a similar material design
to GCP compute and that's on purpose we
wanted to feel like a natural extension
of GCP for you
so while it'll look and feel a lot like
GCP compute but it'll also expose some
of the unique features of our power
technology for example shared cores
versus dedicated core
right so where it makes sense we've
actually made those capabilities
available for you to control as you
build and manage your virtual machines
we've also provided a command-line
interface tool as part of the user
experience and one interesting feedback
that we've had we did a POC last year
with several of our clients and we had
overwhelming feedback that an API and a
CLI was more important than a
point-and-click GUI so we've actually
put more focus on our development
efforts if for the initial the initial
capability around the command-line
interface because that's actually what
the customers told us they wanted and
the command-line interface we built is
called peat cloud if you're used to
using g-cloud compute this is going to
feel very similar to you it's just again
a natural extension and it gives you a
command line model for that virtual
machine management now that you've you
know once you've created these virtual
machines you'll need to access them and
to do that we've built a very innovative
data plane architecture in partnership
with Google
it'll gives you a mechanism so that you
can access the virtual machines in your
cloud instance from a GCP project and
it's again it's a natural extension of
your virtual private cloud set of
networks it's just another network that
gets integrated into your B PC and
provides you know a private IP address
model to control the access to your
virtual machines I'm actually gonna
bring Andy back up to take you through a
little bit more detail of the set of
technologies that have made this type of
integration possible thanks Carl I don't
so I mentioned this earlier and I'll
just give you a little bit more detail
we can follow up later but at Google we
we have a lot of services that we
develop natively that follow a similar
model where the service itself is
exposed over a range of IP addresses
that that you as the customer need to
specify because you have your own IP
addressing scheme you may have on-prem
IP ranges but we're always talking about
you know RFC 1918 private address space
here so for the first time ever we made
this technology available to a partner
and we're and IBM in this case and the
way it works it's based on a and a
aggregation of several Google networking
technologies that were put together in
an architecture so if you were to
subscribe to this offer let's say you
were client 1 you would first initiate
the purchase in the marketplace and then
you would specify a private IP range
that you wish to wish to use you would
reserve that inside your Google V PC in
your project and then we would give you
a peering command which you would need
to run because you know we can't control
your project and what that peering
command does is it peers you to another
V PC inside of Google but that's owned
by IBM and that's that's the end of it
you're the rest of the plumbing network
wise is handled by IBM they have to
obviously you saw they have real
hardware or something behind this so
they have to they handle the hybrid
network connectivity attaching VLANs and
all that but that's all transparent all
you see is some advertised routes for
the IBM l parse and similarly your
routes on your private VLAN are
advertised back so we think that that
you'll find it very very simple to use
most of the complexity is is handled by
the provider IBM in this case and it's
gonna be very similar to if you've ever
used like a Google Cloud sequel it's a
very similar workflow and and there's
many more many more Google services that
are following this model
Oh one thing I guess to point out a case
is not completely obvious there's no no
connectivity into the and to the IBM LP
our world without from the internet
without going through the google without
going through Google cloud to begin with
so that that's important for security
and it gives you all the all the
features that the Google front end has
in order to secure what the workloads
that you're running in IBM yeah so so
thanks for bringing that up Andy so
again a key point here is we wanted to
make sure that when your VM is created
it comes out secure right so it's
protected inside your GCP project is a
private IP and it's really up to you to
decide how you're going to make it
accessible whether you want to open it
up to the Internet through a VPN
solution or a jump server solution or
maybe behind an application server or
maybe you your intention is to run a
direct connect all the way to your
on-prem datacenter and have connectivity
all the way from your your data center
to the back end power
virtual machines so we we wanted to give
you the ability to fully control that
but we and we also wanted you to be able
to leverage the rich diversity of
services that GCP has and their
expertise around networking capabilities
and we're gonna we're gonna wrap up the
presentation here pretty quickly because
we really want to spend time showing you
this and we also want to leave plenty of
time for your questions but if you if
you want to get with us for more details
please contact me or seenu here on the
screen
you've got see their email addresses and
we can have more of a one-on-one
dialogue with you to get more into your
needs and you know more and more into
the details of our of our solution I'm
also there's a questionnaire this
there's a link here to this
questionnaire that we put together it's
a Google form and police you know we
like to have you come and fill out that
form tell us a little bit about your
environment what you see is your
requirements for a cloud-based power
solution and that'll you know that helps
us understand what we need to build but
also helps us understand how we can help
you okay and so with that we're gonna do
a demo to give you a much closer look at
you know what we built and you turn it
over to Kyle
okay my name is Kyle Johnson and I'm a
senior engineer at IBM and I've been
working on more the development side for
this project so today I'm gonna give you
a kind of a walkthrough of this the UI
that we have created and in the CLI so
all this that we've created today we did
build like a full full API for all this
so all of our UI and our CLI is
utilizing that so in the intern we're
kind of you know testing as we go along
our API is with our UI and CLI so today
I want to kind of skip over the kind of
marketplace area so normally in Google
you would go to the marketplace and you
would subscribe you know to this and so
let's just assume that we've already
gone ahead and we subscribe and so now
we're gonna be brought to our kind of
dashboard for managing our power
resources so for the demo Vulcano head
i've already created two partitions and
so real quick we're gonna go in and look
at this demo power and here you can see
the look and feel is very close to what
you would see on GCP we tried to change
the colors a little bit so you wouldn't
get too confused so you might you know
you might think you're actually in DCP
but here you're actually you know
managing your power resources so if you
look you know you get your basic
information that you know the name right
now we have this in data center running
in u.s. East 4 so this is not running on
my laptop this is not running somewhere
in my office back you know in Austin
Texas it was actually running in our
data center so this has all been
deployed you can see here we have an
active state this is running on an IBM
s-92 - we're using of course I beans
kind of shared processor feature and
power hardware we gave it kind of half a
core and then four gigs of memory this
one right here is actually an AIX 7 -
and then down here you kind of manage
your SSH keys that you'd like to deploy
to the VM you can manage any type of
data disk you'd like to attach and then
on this tab here we have this kind of
networking tab and so when you sign up
for this service in Google we're
actually going to go ahead and create
this VPC peering network that's kind of
part of the signup process and so when
you come in to start creating your first
VMs you're gonna have this GCP kind of
network sitting there for you this is
going to be the bridge between your GCP
project and then down into your kind of
power resources you are free to also
create other private networks so you
could actually have a price
network just for your power hardware
maybe for some sort of like
intercommunication but this generally
will be how you can kind of talk to your
x86 to your PPC resources up up up top
here we have some kind of actions you
can run but here I'll just show you that
you can kind of click on the open
console and we're gonna go ahead and
it'll immediately pull up you know the
the ax console to login so then here's a
guy X and I can do an L par stat and you
can see it has four gigs of memory and
0.5 CPU entitlement so you know
everything's kind of driving here okay
let's go ahead and let you do what most
people would do when they log in is
let's go ahead and create a new power
resource so we're going to call this
Google next nineteen UI it's going to be
deployed in our US East for location
we're gonna go ahead and use chair
processors and let's give it one in a
quarter and six gigs of memory we're
gonna go ahead and just use our ax 72
and means that we have out there for us
and then we'll go ahead and just select
kind of our default GCP Network so I'm
gonna go ahead and click create
and you can see here I'm kind of zoomed
in so our UI is kind of crushed but you
can see here it just went ahead and
created this Google next UI some of the
information here is not going to be
available until it all forget fully gets
deployed but on a minute we'll do like a
refresh and I can show you like the IP
and its current state so normally for me
is I use the UI to kind of test the
features and see what's available to me
but when I really want to get some real
work done I usually switch over and kind
of use the COI let's go ahead and give
you a nice good demo of our P cloud CLI
so starting off what okay that too small
for everybody I need a little bigger
okay okay so as you can see we kind of
called our command P cloud to be really
close to G cloud so I guess you know
that the best form of flattery is is
kind of imitation so most of our
commands are going to feel very very
similar to what you would normally run
on G cloud so in this kind of route
context here the main two available
commands that are important to you or
the compute command which is very
similar to g-cloud compute and then
config where you would kind of set your
project so if I go ahead and I click P
cloud compute help you can see the the
kind of main sessions that we've created
here for you to kind of manage your
power hardware the first one is cloud so
this is where you would switch between
what we call a cloud instance for power
like earlier we talked about t-shirts so
this right here would be the different
types of cloud like you could buy
different t-shirts and bundles this is
where you can manage those clouds images
there's all of our oh s images so this
is where you could have your a x7 271
maybe any Linux images you might have
instances are your actual power of VM
instances networks that's where I talked
about earlier it's where you could
create your private networks and also
have your manager your default DCP
network SSH keys or where you can add
new SSH keys to be deployed when you
actually you know provision your
instance and then finally volumes are
all your data volumes
so let's go ahead and list our clouds
and you can see here I have one t-shirt
that I purchased and I called it cloud
nine so we can go ahead and do a
describe on that cloud and you can see
that this cloud I created earlier so
it's kind of small it has 20 processors
and 60 gigs of memory so now I can go
back and type in my config set cloud and
this is kind of going to set up my IP
cloud to just be managing that one cloud
resource okay so now we can go into
compute and let's look at some instances
that we have so you can see here I do
have the two that I showed you earlier
and then even now our new UI Alon is
shown up so we can also dive in a little
deeper and we can look at this demo
power and you can see here we get a lot
more detailed information we have point
five processors again four gigs of
memory showing the IBM system time your
IP address you make MAC address or
network and we give you some IDs so
different volumes that might be attached
or the OS image that's procurement Lee
installed look at SSH keys I do have one
here that I've created before we can
also dive in a little deeper to the SSH
key and you can see here that I also do
support multiple formats so like like
g-cloud you can specify JSON CSV table
camel and it's going to return in that
format if you're familiar with g-cloud
you'll notice that that every command
kind of has a default formatting and we
kind of follow that same suit so most
lists are gonna be in a table format and
then most describes are gonna come back
in yamo but you're always allowed to
override that with the format command
just moving on we can look at images so
images here we have an AIX 72 so that's
kind of been installed into your cloud
instance storage we do have a way here
that IBM's going to keep a collection
like a catalog of images for you to use
that are kind of stock images so if you
do the available command you'll be able
to list all the stock images available
for you to copy into your cloud
next we'll look at networks so you can
see here there's that default GCP
network that I spoke of earlier let's go
ahead and do a describe on that network
so you can see here I get the
information about my cider and IP ranges
that'll be assigned to my partitions
when they're created I have my gateway
you can also assign any type of DNS that
you would like for your instances so you
might actually have a cloud DNS that's
running inside GCP then you can kind of
do the routing for or you can even maybe
deploy your own buying server down in
the in your power color oh you're tired
your cloud instance okay
we'll look at volumes so right now I
have a test volume that was sitting out
there let's go ahead and try to create a
volume so you can see here we have many
options but the two that we really care
about today are gonna be size and the
type of volume you want to create so we
are going to support right out of the
box we're gonna have standard disks and
a flash disk so you'd be able to create
either one when it went creating your
your data volumes so you can see here we
can type in gee a 19 disk we'll give it
a size of 20 and we'll give just well go
ahead and use a standard disk for now so
now our volumes been created so let's go
ahead and actually create an instance on
the command line so here's the help for
that the main thing to take away it's
very similar from earlier on the UI
we're gonna supply an image we're gonna
supply a some memory networks or the
processing you want to use the processor
type which could be shared or dedicated
so today we're gonna actually use shared
and then we can also supply how much
memory you want to use and we're going
to go ahead and we're going to attach
that volume that we just created earlier
as a data volume to this partition so I
go in and enter
so you can see here our instance was
created and so I think a message
takeaway here is you know when we create
these instances it's being deployed into
a cloud so not everything's
instantaneous so right now a lot of
stuff is gonna be you know getting
provision in the backend but we can't go
ahead and do a list and you can see here
we now have a Google 19 CLI that we've
just created and let's dive in a little
deeper we can do a describe
and you can see right now we of course
we specified point five processing we
had four gigs of memory and the the big
thing important here now as I say the
status is in the build status so right
now we're still provisioning this
instance so the builds hats will change
to okay when it's ready to start you
know doing some more operations but some
some information like the networking
that's going to be you know show up
later once it's actually been been
resolved okay but we can't go ahead and
pull up a console so just like the UI
you can run the command for console on
this instance and what its gonna do is
it's gonna return you a like one-time
URL and so when you click on that link
you're gonna be brought to the prompt
here as it's installing AIX so you can
see here from the CLI we've gone ahead
and we've created an instance and then
now we're actually logging in to the
console so we'll give it a few seconds
and then see see being at the prompt to
come up
I guess Umi good deal part now yeah okay
yeah actually now I think I'll switch
and let's do some more oh here we go
well I'll let that run the background
okay let's go ahead and do something
more interesting that's kind of more
available on power so as you may know we
can actually change resources while the
operating system is running so on power
we're gonna do what we call like usually
internally we call like a DL power
operation or dynamic kind of
partitioning so let's go ahead and do a
list let's use the demo power one so
we'll do a describe on demo power and
you can see here as point five
processors and four gigs of memory so
let's go ahead and pull up a console
we're gonna login I'll do an LPR stat to
show you that we have four gigs of
memory sorry it's hard to see the prompt
here four gigs of memory and point five
processors I'm gonna go ahead and do a
VM stat 1 so this is just gonna be like
a simulate just like a job running on
the system so we know that it was
actually live let's go back to my prompt
here and let's go ahead and perform an
update while it's running so let's look
at the update command for instance right
here I think we're really important we
want to just change the processors in
memory
you can also change the name but that
willie wouldn't be a dl part so let's go
ahead and do processors two point six
point seven five and we'll give it six
gigs of memory instead so we're gonna go
up point two five on the processor and
two gigs on the memory let's go and hit
enter
so that's been updated and now we can go
back to our prompt here and while this
is being initiated you're probably gonna
see a little message from AIX telling
you that the processor memory has been
changed right there it kind of showed up
when we click but it's giving you a
telling you that you know we have six
use of memory and point seven five
processors let me go ahead and stop this
prompt I can do an LP our stand you can
see that while I was running we've just
increased to six gigs of memory and
point seven five processors and we can
go back to the sorry I keep leaving the
wrong thing to the command line and we
can do a describe and you will see that
it's also been updated on the command
line so now we're matching what it shows
point seven five and six feats of memory
I think I also I can show you so I'm
actually running this peak cloud inside
of DCP so I I've created in a bunch to a
bunt to instance in my GCP project so I
could technically go ahead and I can
actually ping this this Network all the
way from DCP you know down into power so
this is the full link running so I'm
actually running peak cloud on like just
some random VM that I have in GCP but I
can also you know talk to the network
down in the power Colo so thatthat so
that's the part they talked about
earlier you know with the BC V PC
peering so it's scratching all of it
works we have a fully fledged CLI and
and UI so oh yeah so the latency you can
see it's it's sub you know so one second
millisecond so it's very very fast
oh yeah so real quick let's see
just go back I wanted to show you you
know we created this to our leader I
don't want you to call me a liar so I
want to show you that re X actually did
boot up here so there you go
[Music]